Bienvenidos a resolviendo
una cuadrática por factorización.
Vamos a empezar con algunos problemas,
vamos a empezar con una función "f" de "x"
igual a "x" cuadrada
más 6x más 8.
Y en esta presentación
solo voy a hacer la parte mecánica,
de cómo resolver
este tipo de ecuaciones
y luego ya en otro video
voy a explicar porqué funcionan.
Esencialmente
lo que vamos a querer hacer es
esta función cuadrática,
este polinomio cuadrático,
vamos a querer igualarlo a 0,
es decir
vamos a tener "x" cuadrada más 6x
más 8
lo igualamos a 0.
Entonces esta ecuación como puedes darte cuenta,
a lo mejor
ya querrás intentar resolverlo,
pero este término cuadrático complica todo el asunto,
así que lo que vamos a hacer en este,
en este video va a ser factorizar.
Déjenme ilustrar esencialmente
qué es lo que estamos haciendo.
Déjenme pinto
2 ejes,
no sé exactamente
cómo sea la gráfica de esta función "f" de "x",
de hecho aquí está el eje
"f" de "x"
y este es "x"
y lo que tenemos nosotros
es una parábola,
más o menos así.
Entonces
al igualar a 0 nosotros estamos
encontrando estos puntos de intersección.
¿Por qué?
"f" de "x" igual a 0
sería lo mismo que
posicionarnos sobre este eje.
Entonces queremos encontrar cuando
"f" de "x" es 0, pues es,
justo la intersección de la gráfica
con nuestro eje.
Así que vamos ahora así, a ver
la parte mecánica de cómo resolver esto.
Esencialmente lo que vamos a hacer
para factorizar,
es decir que esta expresión
la vamos a expresar como "x" más algo
por
"x" más algo,
esto es el proceso de factorizar
y eso debe ser igual a 0,
entonces el problema
va a ser encontrar estos 2 números que
me satisfacen que este producto,
sea igual a esta expresión,
y te voy a decir fácilmente cómo encontrarlo,
los números que voy a poner aquí,
deben ser tales que al sumarlos me den 6,
este numerito deben ser
sumados, me debe dar 6
y multiplicados me deben dar 8,
así que vamos a analizar primero
cuáles son todos los factores de 8.
Los factores de 8 pues son,
1, 2
4 y 8
entonces puede uno ir probando,
por ejemplo, 1 por 8 sí es 8
pero 1 más 8 no son 6,
vamos a ver qué pasa con 2 por 4,
2 por 4 son 8, sí
y 2 más 4 sí son 6,
así que aquí vamos a poner el 2
y aquí vamos a poner el 4.
Entonces
ya lo que tenemos es una factorización
y esto nos sirve porque ahora tenemos dos números que multiplicados me dan 0.
Entonces, lo que sí ya sabemos es que si dos números...
al multiplicarse me dan 0,
alguno de ellos debe ser 0,
entonces
"x" más 2
es igual a 0
ó
"x" más 4 es igual a 0.
Entonces lo que vamos a tener,
esto ya es muy sencillo de resolver
porque tenemos que "x" es igual a -2
¿verdad?
Restamos 2 de ambos lados
o bien "x" es igual a -4
y esto ya es
bastante interesante porque
tenemos que de una ecuación,
obtuvimos 2 soluciones distintas,
cuando teníamos ecuaciones en la variable
o ecuaciones lineales,
o ecuaciones de primer grado,
solo teníamos una respuesta,
aquí podemos tener dos
y eso se debe a que la gráfica intersecta en dos puntos .
Entonces solo para que te des una idea
voy a sustituir este -2 en esta expresión de arriba,
y verás que si nos da 0.
Entonces tenemos -2 al cuadrado,
más 6 veces por -2 más 8,
esto es igual a,
-2 al cuadrado son 4
6 por -2 son -12
sumamos 8
y esto es 8 y 4
son 12 menos 12,
sí en efecto es 0,
entonces a ti te va a quedar pendiente
checar que también con - 4 nos da 0,
y entonces estos dos
son las soluciones del problema.
E insisto esto es interesante, el que tengamos dos soluciones
porque la gráfica
intersecta 2 veces a nuestro eje.
Muy bien,
vamos a hacer otro problema.
Digamos,
ahora vamos a tener la función, "f" de "x"
igual a...
y vamos a poner
2x cuadrada
más 20x más 50
y otra vez
lo que vamos a intentar hacer es
encontrar las raíces
o las soluciones de la ecuación,
2x cuadrada más 20x más 50 igual a 0,
y como puedes darte cuenta
hay algo esencialmente distinto
a lo que teníamos en el problema anterior,
y es este número 2 que antecede al "x" cuadrada
entonces,
lo que vamos a hacer es
multiplicar, o más bien vamos a dividir,
ambos lados de la ecuación
entre 2.
Vamos a dividir todo esto entre 2
y aquí también
vamos a dividir entre 2.
Entonces, ¿qué es lo que tenemos
si dividimos entre 2 esta suma?
Es sumar cada uno de ellos
dividido entre 2
2x cuadrada entre 2 es "x" cuadrada,
20x entre 2 son 10x,
50 entre 2 son 25
y la ventaja que tenemos
es que 0 entre 2 sigue siendo 0
y ya tenemos una ecuación,
exactamente igual
que la que teníamos anteriormente.
Entonces ya podemos hacer el mismo truco
que habíamos hecho,
decir que esto se escribe
como "x" más algo por "x" más algo
y que esto me da 0.
Ahora bien,
¿qué es lo que necesitamos encontrar?
2 números que sumados me den 10
y que multiplicados me den 25.
Así que,
vamos a analizar
los factores de 25
esto es, 1, 5 y 25
son todos los factores posibles de 25,
y por ejemplo 1 por 25 es 25
pero 1 más 25 no son 10,
así que lo único que nos queda
es 5 por 5 que es 25
y 5 más 5 es 10, así que,
ya lo obtuvimos.
Ya obtuvimos los 2 números que van aquí,
de hecho
son iguales para que...
este es un buen ejemplo para que veas
que no tienen que ser necesariamente distintos,
podrían ser iguales
¿verdad?
Así que, de hecho, ya que tenemos esto pues
el producto de 2 números que me da 0,
necesariamente alguno tiene que ser 0,
es decir
"x" más 5 es igual a 0
ó
"x"...
déjenme cambiar esta "o"
para que se vea más,
que se vea la diferencia de ó y 0,
y esto es "x" más 5 igual a 0,
y de hecho estas 2 ecuaciones son las mismas
¿verdad?
Y la única solución que tenemos es
"x" igual a -5,
y entonces tú me vas a decir,
"Oye pero tú me habías dicho que son dos soluciones
a estas ecuaciones cuadráticas,
¿Qué es lo que está pasando?"
Aquí sólo obtuvimos una solución.
Vamos a ver qué es lo que
ocurre en la gráfica.
Déjenme hacer esto
un poquito más derecho.
Más o menos,
digamos que aquí está el -5
y está  función
tiene forma de parábola,
y si sólo tengo una solución,
quiere decir que por aquí viene mi parábola,
le da un toquecito al eje
y luego se sigue subiendo.
Entonces aquí solo tuvimos una solución,
porque,
porque toca tangencialmente
a nuestro eje "x"
y para que veas que
no te estoy enseñando mal,
vamos a ver que "x" más 5, por "x" más 5,
es esta expresión de arriba.
"x" más 5 por "x" más 5
es igual a
"x" que multiplica a "x" más 5,
usando la propiedad distributiva y luego,
5 que multiplica a "x" más 5
y entonces "x" por "x"
es "x" cuadrada
"x" por 5 son 5x,
5 por "x" son otras 5x
y luego 5 por 5 son 25.
Entonces si agrupamos estos términos, me queda
"x" cuadrada más 10x más 25.
Vámonos con otro último ejemplo.
Vamos a
tomarnos digamos
"x" cuadrada menos "x" menos 30
igual a 0.
Entonces nuevamente buscamos dos números,
que al sumarlos me den,
me den - 1
y que multiplicados me den -30,
vamos a escribirlo,
estoy buscando números
"a" y "b", tal que al sumarlos, me den -1
y al multiplicarlos me den -30,
y como puedes darte cuenta,
aquí la cosa cambia porque tenemos un signo menos,
así que vamos a tomar...
vamos a ver todos los factores de 30
que son 1, 2, 3,
5, 6,
10, 15
y por supuesto 30.
Entonces si nos damos cuenta,
la multiplicación de estos números
deben ser de signos opuestos,
porque si tienen el mismo signo, por ejemplo,
que sea más por más, pues me da más
si es menos por menos
también me da más,
así que necesito que sean de signos opuestos,
y por otro lado deben ser tales
que la suma nos de - 1
Es un número negativo,
entonces por ejemplo puede uno tomar el 1 por 30
y pues sí nos...
bueno,
ahí quizás deberíamos ver los signos
pero, es muy fácil ver
y vas a ir agarrando práctica con esto,
que si tenemos
-6 y 5
entonces obtenemos el resultado,
-6 por 5 son -30
y -6 más 5 son -1.
Entonces tenemos -6 más 5,
de lo cual podemos concluir que
"x" debe ser igual a 6,
¿verdad?
Si esto lo igualamos a 0
entonces "x" menos 6 es 0
ó bien "x" es igual a 6,
ó por otro lado,
"x" más 5 es 0,
de donde "x" es igual a -5
y estas son mis 2 soluciones.
Yo sé que el inicio
puede parecer confuso pero,
veremos más adelante
porqué es válido este método,
y veremos más ejemplos.
Quizás ya estés listísimo para
resolver otras ecuaciones cuadráticas
y también haré otros videos
para que tengas más ejercicios de práctica.
Que te diviertas.